so Leute was geht ich bin gerade wieder
bei Mo Tag hier und wollte ein paar neue
Retouren Paletten einkaufen was hast
denn so neues da jede Menge kannst ja
mal ein paar hundert Paletten sehen wenn
Du möchtest
zack hier vorne besser auf jeden Fall
eine gute Auswahl ja bügelkisten für
Flohmarkt Händler oh nein nicht schon
wieder Flohmarkt große und kleine Sachen
drin
aber ich glaube das schon mal so eine
Erfahrung gemacht was kostet eine
Box kostet jetzt äh je nach Kilogramm
das wird per Kilogramm okay
diese Palette ja das weiß jetzt gar
nicht muss sagen so vielleicht 1000 €
echt
krass ja was ist das
renommierten Bauhaus haben
jetzt auf jeden Fall mal wieder dick
eingekauft für dreieinhalb tausend Euro
hier bei Mode checken auf jeden Fall bei
tiktok aus weil hier gibt's alles
Retouren soweit das Auge reicht genau